[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à terry
d'interdire la rupture par l'australie
du contrat signé en 2016 avec la france
portant sur 12 sous marin remplacé
illico pas des sous marins américains
n'en finit pas de faire des vagues il
faut dire que l'humiliation est de
taille l'ex premier ministre australien
kevin ruud a que son successeur scott
morrison d'avoir sapé les relations avec
la france et l'union européenne dans des
fèves ursula von der leyen a jugé
inacceptable la façon dont la france a
été traité le gouvernement australien se
défendent expliquant que les français
ont été aveugle à ses mises en garde
notre ministre de notre ministère de la
défense lui rétorque que la france
construit des sous marins depuis 120 ans
et que c'est donc bien l'odeur de
l'industrie française qui est en jeu à
new york où se tient l'assemblée
générale de l'onu le président des états
unis le premier ministre britannique et
le premier ministre australien se sont
rencontrés mais n'ont pas répondu aux
questions des journalistes concernant la
faire heureusement joe biden emmanuel
macron se sont parlé on ne sait pas
encore ce qu'ils se sont dit mais on
peut espérer que la guerre et éviter une
affaire donc sujette à pas mal de
questions questions que je vais
m'empresser de poser à mes invités qu'il
dira ely directeur de la publication du
magazine causeur et directeur de la
rédaction de la revue conflit à qui la
faute
si on a perdu le contrat du siècle
puisque les superlatifs sont nombreux
dans cette affaire ça 80 milliards c'est
je pense que d'abord que le sous marin
ne sont pas au centre de la sphère que
c'est d'abord une question de détention
qui sont en train de monter entre les
etats-unis et la chine qu'on entre dans
une quasi guerre froide et donc si je
doit désigner une seule console acteurs
ce sera plutôt les présidents chinois
qui est en rupture avec les précédents
et qui fait monter les enchères et la
pression ce soir à taiwan que ce soit
dans les îles
la mer de chine du sud
ce soit hong kong
la chine est passé à la vitesse
supérieure et les états unis ont décidé
de prendre les choses en main ils sont
dans une configuration de la fin des
années 20 des douze années 30 kohno
menace
japonaise commencé à monter sur
l'horizon oui en gros il nous rejouer la
guerre du pacifique avec les états unis
la grande bretagne et l'australie plus
ou moins plus ou moins ils avaient leurs
porte-avions de l'atlantique et les îles
britanniques et un porte-avions qui est
australie dans le dans le pacifique et
entre deux guerres mondiales on peut
laisser les puissances de deuxième
langue de jouer mais quand les choses
deviennent très sérieuse se dire quand
on risque de faire appeler aux gi's pour
nous sauver là ils disent bon écoutez
vous attendez un d'ideye donc laissez
nous aujourd'hui nous préparer parce que
c'est les cendres de nos enfants qui va
être un jour bientôt
sylvie matelly vous êtes économiste
directrice adjointe à l'iris l'institut
des relations internationales et
stratégiques vous avez publié récemment
eu d'yeux géopolitique de l'économie
avec 40 fiches illustrées pour
comprendre le monde aux éditions
eyrolles même question à qui la faute
pour vous
alors on attribuer la faute la chine
effectivement d'avoir durci ses
positions et puis surtout avec
l'australien la chine et est quand même
à véritablement était extrêmement dur
ces derniers ces derniers mois avec
l'australie imposant un embargo sur un
certain nombre de produits on a accusé
l'australie en australie on se rend
compte que c'est une question
extrêmement politique en fait le choix
de la relation à la chine et le choix du
positionnement par rapport à cette
relation à la chine puisque l'ancien
premier ministre a fortement critiqué
son successeur
expliquant qu'il allait à la catastrophe
en ayant fait le choix américain plutôt
que plutôt que le choix de coopération
avec avec la france on pourrait penser
aussi qu'il ya quand même des torts côté
français alors passez sur la rupture du
contrat en tant que tel mais de pain de
ne pas avoir vu le changement de de
premier ministre en australie et les
conséquences que ça pouvait avoir ne
n'avoir pas su percevoir ce
mécontentement australien et de ne pas
l'avoir rassuré et puis bien évidemment
sont également visés les etats-unis et
le royaume-uni puisque ce sont quand
même eux qui sont allés qui sont allés
aussi chercher convaincre l'australie de
renoncer à ce contrat donc les torts
sont très certainement partagés quand
comme dans tout dans tout mariage si on
peut qualifier une coopération de deux
mariages nathalie goulet sénatrice de
l'union centriste de l'orne vous avez
puisse président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées secrétaire et du groupe
d'amitié france australie au sénat c'est
vous qui avez demandé lundi la création
d'une commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
sur les conditions de lecture du contrat
et les conséquences au plan industriel
et stratégique pour vous à qui la faute
oh je crois que je crois que je vais je
vais suivre ce qui vient d'être dit
d'abord je voulais vous prier de bien
vouloir excuser la faiblesse de la
connexion méchoui au bénin donc c'est
pas trés c'est pas très pratique c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'étais un peu
en retard
oui je pense que les torts sont
évidemment partagé mais mais si vous
voulez le point d'interrogation c'est
qu'une affaire comme ça ne peut pas se
déboucler en une nuit et
et il faut aussi aller chercher
les causes et les modalités qui ont qui
ont précédé cette rupture c'est en cela
qu une commission d enquête serait
importante alors pour votre parfaite
information la conférence des présidents
au sénat hier à refuser la commission
d'enquêté également demandée par le
groupe socialiste au motif que la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées allait
faire des auditions
jeu pas très sûr que des auditions grand
place une commission denquête donc je
suis pas très sûr qu'on aura les tenants
et les aboutissants de cette affaire
tout de suite
effectivement est-ce que c'est sans
précédent à cas comme celui-là j'ai
l'impression que le
la concurrence est elle entrée table
pour pour les contrats d'armement tu les
pressions sur les acheteurs sont général
ou à la hauteur des boutons on entend
parler constamment de contrats qui ont
été adulés
alors jeune exemple en tête c'est
l'exemple des ravitailleurs en vol
herveux c'était un concours ans contre
boeing airbus était je pense qu'elle
russe a gagné et puis des américains ont
fait annuler l'appel d'offres
globales beau la communauté
internationale
n'est pas une république ya pas de
gendarme
et donc les pays les différents pays
sont pas comme le citoyen dans une
république dans un état de droit et les
états ne sont pas des humains la france
n'est pas en colère
les états unis n'est pas injuste s'étend
en inde l'angle où les animaux sauvages
sont son l'apparence de gentlemen c'est
tout le rapport des forces donc je pense
que chaque fois qu'un pays qui est plus
fort que l'autre juge que ses intérêts
vitaux
et dans l'intérêt vite au jeu coup jean
clôt aussi le fait qu'un chef d'état
considère que ça pollue le plus ferrai
se faire réélire donc c'est parce que
évidemment chacun pense que sans lui son
état s'est c'est court à la catastrophe
donc sa réélection c'est l'intérêt vital
de son état etc etc donc chaque fois
qu'on est dans une telle considération
il n'y a pas de lois internationales
il n'y a pas des règles on essaie après
dé raconter n'importe quoi de comme dans
chaque grand projet il y avait des
preuves il y avait une des énormes
problèmes dans la gestion de projets
mais je connais pas un seul grand projet
d'armement qui a tenu les délais et les
budgets ça n'existait pas or c'est ce
que laissent entendre les australiens 7
on n'allait pas respecté les délais et
le budget c'est probablement vrai mais
c'est probablement vrai faut à la fois
c'est à dire si on commençait déjà à
couper de la ferraille peut-être y
seraient pas
changes devrait pas changer d'avis mais
c'est vrai aussi pour les
réacteurs nucléaires en finlande et en
france
c'était vrai pour le rafale c'est très
souvent les cas il ya des sénatrices ici
qui se connaît mieux que moi c'est très
rare qu'on tient les délais et les
budgets aux états unis regardons les
projets f 35 les assesseurs si on vaut
rire il faut il faut lire le les délais
et les budgets dans les textes des biens
20 ans ça fait ce fait rigoler oui et
non donc c'est à la fois un argument qui
est vrai et qu'il faut donc c'est
éminemment politique elle à l'australie
et à décider que nous sommes dans un
scénario en et 30 face au japon et à ce
moment là ce sont des décisions qui sont
plutôt logique on y reviendra mais
est-ce qu'à des préfets dans pour vous
allez vous les
écoutez je les ai pas en mémoire et des
précédents de rater je pense notamment
aux centrales nucléaires civiles aux
émirats arabes unis on s'est fait
souffler et contrat par les coréens
malgré le travail de notre ambassadeur
de l'époque parce qu areva
ne répondait pas aux préconisations qui
était demandée et s'obstiner à proposer
quelque chose que les emiriens ne
voulait pas bon bref avant avant que les
contrats soient si oui oui c'était à
bord du oui c'est ça mais j'ai pas dit
oui bien sûr mais là j'ai pas de jets
pas je voudrais g mais c'était quand
même aussi un signe de difficultés de
notre diplomatie économique mais là on
est dans un vrai problème les
australiens peuvent très bien changer de
besoin
c'est tout à fait entendent abl qu'ils
aient changé et qu'ils aient évolué sur
leurs besoins ce qui est pas entendable
c'est la méthode qu'ils ont utilisés
pour rompre ce contrat et l'humiliation
galactique
de notre pays et de chacun d'entre eux
si vous voulez il ya quand même là
quelque chose qui mérite
ce que gisèle et que la représentation
nationale notamment comprenne ce qui
s'est passé et des explications lui
battait les préfets bruit alors il ya
des ya des précédents mais je les ai pas
en tête non plus et c'est déjà arrivé et
pas forcément sur des contrats
d'armement mais simplement ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre aussi
c'est que si les retards avaient été
pris les retards qui nous ont été
reprochés car justifier la rupture du
contrat c'est parce que les australiens
ne voulait pas de propulsion nucléaire
ce qu'on aurait été en mesure quasiment
de leur livrer dans les mois qui
viennent en réalité vous voulez vous
l'êtes innover et voulait delà de la
propulsion
diesel donc ça c'est un premier élément
très important et ce qui est d'autant
plus malhonnête dans l'argument qui nous
est servie par les australiens c'est
qu'en réalité ils vont acquérir des
sous-marins américains ou britanniques
qui ne seront livrées que dans quelques
unes ou 2d peut même deux ou trois
décennies donc avec beaucoup plus de
retard que ne l'aurait été les sous
marins français donc vous voyez que
voilà on est sur une arme facile mais
qui ne tient pas la route par contre
c'est certain alors ya une petite
différence je crois il faut bien
comprendre la différence qu'il ya à
vendre des armements quand on est
américain et quand on est quand on est
français ou européens les européens et
les français en particulier ont soutenu
et ont permis la le maintien et la
survie de leur industrie défense depuis
le début des années 90 et la fin de la
guerre froide les dividendes de la paix
les baisses des dépenses militaires ont
permis grâce à la diversification des
clients c'est-à-dire avant les années 90
dans les laits pendant la guerre froide
le principal client de l'industrie
d'armement française c'était l'état
français à partir des années 90 ça ne
suffisait plus pour assurer la survie de
cette industrie surtout que les
équipements militaires sont de plus en
plus coûteux nécessite de plus en plus
d'investissements et pour innover pour
rester en supériorité stratégique
il faut accepter ses investissements
d'au thônex donc ont exporté et au fond
exporter ou perdre contrats export c'est
aussi mettre en péril notre sécurité
nationale parce qu'à un moment donner
c'est une industrie qui se retrouve
affaibli on n'est pas du tout du tout
dans la même situation aux états unis
aux etats unis la question de
l'exportation est une question
uniquement politique et c'est ce qui se
joue en réalité et je pense que c'est de
là que vient aussi l'incompréhension de
joe biden à notre réaction à cette
rupture de contrat c'est que lui joue
son jeu et défend ses intérêts et ils
pensent que tout état est capable de
défendre ses intérêts sans avoir compris
que nous nos intérêts dans ce contrat il
était aussi dans la la bonne santé de
notre industrie de défense la capacité à
innover toujours de notre industrie de
défense et donc il mais de ce fait en
péril pourrait mettre en péril notre
notre sécurité nationale et ça c'est
extrêmement important à préciser parce
que je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
incompréhension entre entre les deux
pays mais nous avons pris justement je
pense que peut-être les américains ne
voient pas d'un mauvais oeil le fait que
dans 10 ou 15 ans les européens seront
obligés d'aller faire leurs courses chez
eux et bientôt il y aura à l'ordre du
jour la question de la plate forme
aérienne pour remplacer le rafale les
allemands
sont pas très chauds pour un avion
fabriqué par dassault dont quinze jours
de sixième génération rafale
et donc je pense que les américains
serait très heureux si dans 20 ou 30 ans
les européens achètent en effe 36 aux 45
et que ici il ya juste deux des ateliers
pour pour réparer les avions ou quelques
quelques quelques usines qui fabriquent
quelques missiles des radars des
avionique et c'est un petit peu
transfert transformer le héros penseurs
d'israël vous fabriquez pas d'effets des
plateformes mais vous pouvez jouer avec
l'électronique et les trucs sympas des
casses des casques de intelligente de ma
jamais vous faites pas des plates formes
principales
ni d'avion ni des sous marins ni des
frégates ni des chars ça vous achetez
chez nous donc je pense que si
l'une des conséquences de ces problèmes
avec les contrats attaque serra le
disons le
l'amoindrissement de la capacité de
l'industrie de défense européenne les
américains vont pas pleurer
autres autre question alors on a entendu
la cellule d concert de lamentations en
français et et alors on va dire entre
alliés fait se fait pas ça c'est nicolas
sarkozy
le chantage aux alliés marche énormément
jean yves le drian a parlé de trahison
de washington
on parle de rupture de confiance
comme si nous n'étions pas en
concurrence avec les américains de la
vraie concurrence commerciale pour
vendre des armes tout simplement déry
concurrent as moi on n'est plus des
alliés
non mais
oui nathalie goulet
on peut des concurrents avant la
signature d'un contrat quand le contrat
est signé c'est tout à fait différent il
est attribué il est signé dans ces cas
là les choses se passent un peu
différemment donc si vous voulez il faut
distinguer les étapes du dispositif mais
moi je soutiens qu'on est absolument
cocu dans cette affaire alors
le titre de votre émission va bien parce
que à qui la faute là je pense qu'il va
falloir décortiqué les opérations
et puis après en tirer des conséquences
mais pour répondre à la question qui est
posée à qui la sonde si les torts sont
partagés
il faut identifier à quel moment on a eu
des avertissements il ya un rapport de
2020 des australiens qui explique qu'on
est en retard que la facture dérape et
c'est bon
donc ça c'est possible parce qu'on n'y a
pas fait assez attention à nos services
est ce que nos services de renseignement
n'ont absolument pas vu se tricoter
derrière leur dos c'est à dire à notre
nez à notre barde un accord important
entre l'australie les états unis et la
grande bretagne parce qu'il ya aussi cet
accord là qui s'est nouée pendant ce
temps là donc c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui qu'on arrive dans cet état
là sans avoir eu des avertissements donc
ça c'est la période antérieure une fois
qu'on aura identifié ça il faudra
prendre évidemment des mesures
nécessaires pour que ça se reproduise
pas alors est ce qui est intéressant qui
est intéressant c'est pour ne pas être
trahi par ses alliés il faut le trahir
le dire il faut espionner les
australiens pour savoir ce qu'ils
concoctent
rapport aux approches sont reprochés à
nos services ce n'est pas avoir espionné
les appelait les australiens et les
américains
je dis pas ça comme ça je dis qu'un tel
acte un tel accord n'a pas pu passer
inaperçue voilà qu'on a des services qui
sont faits pour ça voilà donc je
m'interroge simplement je suis comme
tout le monde je pose des questions et
tant que j'aurai pas des réponses et
bien je serai toujours interrogative
alors vers jean ne vais quand même pas
dans une cour on n'est pas dans une cour
de récréation
je me pose la question si au lieu de
parler de contrats rompus on parlait
d'un agent
français qui a été arrêté dans
l'ambassade des états unis à cabara avec
des documents donc là j'imagine que les
australiens et les américains auraient
crié quelques elle quelle trahison
comment on peut faire ça entre entre
alliés ça se fait pas on a un problème
de confiance maintenant
il faut faire parce que j'ai dit en
thérapie de couple c'est pas du tout ce
que j'ai ici j'en aurai sais je sais je
sais que j'essaye juste d'aller un petit
peu plus loin mais c'est en fait c'est
ça c'est pour cela que terry carr
espionne sur les allemands
à mon avis ça va déjà assez loin sans
qu'on ait besoin d'en rajouter bien sûr
bien sûr en version mais si vous voulez
un accord comme ça entre les états unis
l'australie et la grande bretagne
c'est quand même quelque chose qui doit
se percevoir enfin je veux dire c'est
pas possible qu'ils passent totalement
inaperçus ce que je dis on a les
services de renseignement qui auraient
pu peut-être dessiner les signaux je dis
pas qu'il faut espionner jeudi corps bon
on a quand même des services qui sont
capables et heureusement et qui sont
très bons qu'ils sont capables de
déceler parfois des opérations même
discrète c'est à ça que ça sert des
services de renseignement oui sinon je
ressens quelques de bic est aujourd'hui
fondamental est évidemment que les
services secrets s'en donnent à coeur
joie
sylvie leroux
sévit batelli
oui là on parle justement de les les
français ont sorti des lettres envoyées
par les australiens leurs dix hommes et
tout va bien tout va bien on passe en
face d'eux par exemple et et qui sont
des lettres très récente alors est ce
que ça veut bien dire ce que ça
sous-entendrait qu'on a voulu jusqu'au
dernier moment on a mené les français
n'ont pas aux sous marins mais en bateau
et on nous a si amant trompé et
et en nous mentant effrontément
une enquête permettrait de le savoir et
de récupérer toutes les pièces et ne
savons pas ce qui s'est exactement passé
mais il est très clair que dans cette
affaire là on parlait tout à l'heure de
concurrencer au fond est ce qu on n'est
pas dans une logique de concurrence la
concurrence elle ne vaut que si elle est
loyal or rappelez vous les français ont
remporté un appel d'offres est
vraisemblablement ou alors les français
sont vraiment vraiment très très très
peu perspicace et et pour pas dire
aveugles ils n'ont pas vu sortir de
nouvel appel d'offres demandant une
modification du du programme donc on
n'est pas dans une situation on est
quand même dans une situation où on nous
la joue et on nous a forcés à vous savez
le répondre à un appel d'offres sur ce
type de programme ça coûte extrêmement
cher parce que ça dure des années parce
que vous êtes obligés de d'être mieux
disant que vos concurrents parce que il
ya tout il ya un investissement de
techniciens d'ingénieurs de spécialistes
de rome 1-2 pour pour rédiger ses appels
d'offres et puis tout d'un coup à une
fois que vous l'avez gagnée que vous
avez commencé à travailler que vous avez
commencé à investir on vous dira ah bah
non il y en a d'autres qui
tout à fait en a changé d'avis et sa
très clairement ça très clairement ça ne
se fait pas qu'on ait des torts parce
qu'on n'a peut-être pas vu les alertes
qu'on ait accepté naïvement des lettres
qui venaient nous rassurer c'est une
chose in an ça n'enlève rien au fait que
de l'autre côté il ya des procédures qui
n'ont pas été respectées et je pense
d'ailleurs on a beaucoup parlé des
compensations qu'ils allaient devoir
être versée à la france je suis pas sûr
qu'il y ait énormément de compensation
sur le contrat en tant que tel par
contre il pourrait y avoir probablement
des décisions de justice qui obligent
l'état australien a
dédommager la france et navales groupe
pour ne pas avoir respecté les règles de
passation des marchés publics en
australie d'ailleurs ça ça nous coûte
combien cette affaire on sait l'argent
qu'on va perdre ce qu'on parle d'un
contrat de 50 millions de dollars
australiens outre le fait qu'on ne sait
pas combien vaut le dollar australien
2 milliards gediminas milliards 50
milliards de dollars australiens est ce
qu'on sait combien on a perdu dans cette
histoire je dit on comme on dit on a
perdu la coupe du monde mais oui c'est
pas évidemment nous les français je
pense passer les françaises
et les français c'est notre bridget et
mark ellis et le commerce extérieur oui
c'est nous c'est chacun d'entre nous
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi violent
tous humilié tout à fait alors
d'abord on sait pas
quel justement ça fait partie de ce
dynamique de gestion des projets très
très compliqué est ce qu'on sait combien
on va nous coûter le giro dès 2024 on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui donc on ne sait pas
si
ça suivi son cours on sait pas combien
d'argent a été dépensé on ne sait pas si
à la fin la france aurait gagné de
l'argent alors ce que ce que la seule
chose que je peux dire c'est que ce qui
aurait pu rester en france est loin loin
loin des ces chiffres annoncés parce que
l'essentiel de travaux
était supposé avoir lieu effectuez un
australie donc à nice en france ces
problèmes en quelques bons milliards de
2 067 8 qui sont plutôt de l'ordre de
bureau d'études beaucoup beaucoup de
formations il ya à mon avis plusieurs
dizaines de familles de se dire de
d'officiers des techniciens et des
d'équipage qui sont à lorient
évidemment des plus en plus les longues
des années et donc beaucoup de chefs de
projets beaucoup de bureaux d'études
mais disons que si c'était 50 aux 60
millions milliards pardon je dirais
qu'entre 10 et 15 % à peu près c'est la
seule globale qui aurait pu arriver en
france et qui n'est pas un profil savait
pas un profil c'est de l'argent dépensé
dans l'économie française nathalie
goulet oui je pense qu'il ya deux choses
il ya l'investissement qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant si vous voulez c'est
à la fois le gain la réparation ce qui a
été dépensé et puis aussi la perte de
champhol le reste du contrat qui a pas
été fait je crois que les australiens
propose 250 millions d'indemnisations
pour bar rompu le contrat moi j'ai pas
eu le contrat entre les mains je sais
pas s'il ya une clause de rupture
anticipée ça c'est une affaire purement
juridique qui doit se régler
probablement avec un arbitrage
sa réparera pas l'humiliation
cv matelly a je crois qu on a perdu la
liaison avec avec sylvie matelly
quoi il ya quand même que c'est aux
multiples pourquoi on en a fait à ce
point des tonnes parce que vous parler
d'humiliation nathalie goulet mais c'est
le fait qu'on soit à ce point indignés
et qu'on aille jusqu'à rappeler nos
ambassadeurs aux états unis lors de ce
rallye ce qu'on n'avait jamais fait on a
donné une importance qui au fond nous
humains tôt si on est humilié c'est
peut-être conduit à un peu participé non
écoutez je crois qu'il ya eu un choc des
modalités et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé cette commission
denquête d'ailleurs je pense qu'on leur
a pas pour plein de raisons parce que
parce que chacun se tient par la
barbichette avant les élections
présidentielles mais mais je crois que
c'était tellement important de connaître
les modalités qui ont précédé cette
rupture
si vous voulez je crois que si elle est
arrivé pendant la nuit ça veut dire que
vous pouvez rompre un contrat de 46
milliards d'euros plus facilement qu'une
ligne chez des feux téléphonique chez un
grand opérateur en vous et vous aide les
états unis oui mais voilà que les états
unis ville voilà voilà oui mais bien sûr
mais sur ce que les états unis n'étaient
pas parties contractantes parce que
c'est quand même un contrat ya un client
il ya un cynisme donc si vous voulez
évidemment c'est de la géostratégie
évidemment ça nous dépasse complètement
mais je comprends s'il ya eu aucun
aucune alerte préalable
si tout le monde a été
rassuré l'avant veille que tout allait
très bien avec ce contrat extra et
comprend un grand coup dans le dos c'est
quand même normal qu'on ait cette
réaction je veux donc on restera je vous
interromps ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
émission consacré cette semaine aux
cryptes aux monnaies sont elles l'avenir
de l'économie
oui les crypto bonnaire en place la
monnaie fiduciaire elle remplace même
lors la province du bitcoin c'est
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
de toute façon à la fin des femmes les
monnaies qu'on connaît actuellement
vaudront 0 aujourd'hui on voit très bien
que les banques centrales cherchent à
faire leurs preuves et aux monnaies
parce que elles veulent garder la main
dessus et ça les intéresse pas du tout
d'avoir un concurrent qui est un
concurrent libre mais quand elle s le
bitcoin ne fait pas partie de ce système
personne ne le contrôle
ça ne va pas seulement changer les
banques centrales ça va changer le
concept même de l'état nation
le bitcoin c'est une monétisation de
l'amour et de la paix des braves
[Musique]
le cuir des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artarit c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
infarctus chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
de son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention on aimerait un
système très curatif 1 c'est essentiel
d'avoir l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur les affaires des
sous marins je devais de vous acheter
l'australie avec nathalie goulet qui est
sénatrice
de l'union centriste de l'orne
et qui a demandé une commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale sur la question
dont elle nous dit d'ailleurs elle-même
qu'elle a probablement qu'elle ne sera
probablement pas accepté avec sylvie
matelly qui est directrice adjoint à
l'iris qu'on a perdu mais qu'on va
retrouver illico et avec guy lemire ali
qui est le directeur de la publication
du magazine causeur et le directeur de
la rédaction de la revue conflit sur les
conséquences
nathalie goulet
on a parlé des conséquences sur notre
sur notre
notre indépendance stratégique mais
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres conséquences on
parle d'humiliation donc humiliation j
aurait des conséquences pour l'industrie
française pour notre image pour l'otan
oui mais moi je trouve que le président
de la république fait très bien de ne
pas faire de déclarations pour l'instant
tonitruante ça sert à rien il a envoyé
ses troupes bon je pense qu'il faut
vraiment évaluer maintenant les
conséquences et éventuellement la
riposte mais si on peut pas faire
confiance aux américains si on peut pas
faire confiance aux britanniques ont ça
on connaît dans ces cas là il faut
revoir aussi
le temps et quand il nous a dit à
quelques mois que le temps était en mort
cérébrale vous savez il ya quelques
années on a eu plus j'étais à
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan et
on a eu plusieurs réunions pour revoir
le concept stratégique de l'otan
on a perdu nathalie goulet qu'il allait
là le concept stratégique de l'otan il
ya quelques années on avait eu plusieurs
réunions pour revoir ce concept
stratégique de l'otan on a mis en place
un nouveau concept stratégique qui était
complètement du pipeau péruvien la
preuve c'est que ça fonctionne toujours
pas donc se reposer la question du
positionnement de le temps et du travail
avec nos alliés quand on a vu ce qui
s'était aussi passé avec la turquie etc
vous et je crois que votre pneu
autre intervenant a raison c'est quand
même une jungle le droit international
n'existe pas l'école la communauté
internationale
on voit le droit international n'existe
plus il a le droit national n'existe pas
la communauté internationale n'existe
pas il n'y a pas de tribunaux
internationaux pour ça donc je crois
qu'on est dans une période où on peut
réfléchir à d'autres alliances oui je
pense que c'est possible
ce n'est pas telle est
la difficulté c'est quel autre alliance
parce qu'on voit l'attachement des
européens à cette alliance atlantique
alors on est en train de renégocier un
concept stratégique qui se heurtent
c'est vrai à la vision européenne c'est
à dire lié les américains veulent mettre
la chine à toutes les sauces veulent
absolument qu'on en fasse l'ennemi
numéro un et qu'on s'organise sur cet
aspect là mais les européens sont pas
tout à fait sur la même île mais en même
temps sont ils prêts à construire
quelque chose en européen c'est ce qui
est en train de se mettre en place mais
à accélérer suffisamment la la démarche
pour que demain on puisse assurer notre
sécurité se passer de l'otan or sans les
européens avec qui va tomber construire
une nouvelle alliance c'est un peu la
question qu'on peut se poser et c'est là
que c'est très compliqué c'est là qu'on
peut répondre à tous les gens qui ont
suggéré une une sortie du retrait du
commandement intégré de l'otan de la
france qu'on l'avait fait par le passé
simplement pour faire quoi en fait pour
faire quoi qu'elles soient nos alliés
aujourd'hui et je crois qu'on n'est plus
en situation de guerre froide telles
qu'elles étaient pendant là pendant la
guerre froide dans les années dans les
années 50 60 70 80 et que on peut plus
permettre deux de s'isoler et de partir
seul c'est un peu ça la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que le temps ont
changé le défi de l'affrontement entre
la chine et des états unis et d'un
véritable défi auquel l'europe peut
probablement proposer une troisième voie
une voie plus multilatérale une voie
moins d'à août en mai de construction de
capitalisation sur des internautes
d'autres intérêts c'est ce qui a été
c'est ce qui a été proposé par par les
pays européens et par la commission
européenne
et donc aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on peut
s'isoler aussi de ça et sortir de l'otan
ont renoncé à l'alliance atlantique ça
signifie quand même aussi ça faut y
penser j'arrive au natal et rigoler
parce que vous pouvez donc compter oui
je sais je suis tout à fait d'accord
c'est pour ça que je me disais qu'il est
très important que le président de la
république réfléchissent pour pas je
dire c'est pas ta été vilain et je veux
pas tu invites est mon anniversaire je
veux dire on n'est pas dans un dosage
non mais attendez on est on est pas dans
un rapport un fond de primaires
infantile etc on est membre du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies et je
pense que la réponse doit être réfléchie
c'est pour ça que tout le monde peut se
poser des questions sur le temps il
président de la république fait bien de
ne pas riposter de cette façon là avant
d'avoir évalué avec nos partenaires
européens et les américains a évidemment
et les britanniques pour avoir une
réflexion mature sur ce qu'il faut faire
mais c'est évident qu'il faut reposer
les cartes sur la table et et mettre en
place un nouveau dispositif où les
européens seront aussi solidaire parce
que comme moi je suis en afrique
l'opération barca de la sécurité de
l'afrique etc les européens on les voit
quand même pas beaucoup donc si vous
voulez tout ça doit être remis
tranquillement sur la table moi je
trouve que le silence du président de la
république est un silence qui pour
l'instant ne semble intelligent et je
vous laisse parce que malheureusement je
suis je suis dans des conditions de de
communication assez acrobatique mais
c'est nathalie goulet d'avoir participé
à ce débat guy lemire et lee vous le
disiez pour vous on est en train les
américains sont en train de refaire la
guerre du pacifique avec la chine dans
le rôle que tenait par la seconde guerre
mondiale le japon mais toujours avec la
grande bretagne et l'australie
est ce que ça veut dire que la france
n'a plus aucun rôle à jouer dans cette
région d'abord en point sémantique on
appelait ça plein longtemps le pacifique
haussant fils y gère région maintenant
on appelle ça la lande de pacific donc
on ne parlait beaucoup de pacifique mais
pas dans le dos et c'est pas donc la
france quand on parle d'un dos pacifique
la france est présent et légitime
des mayotte réunion jusqu'à la polynésie
française donc on est sur place et une
souris les nouvelles calédoniennes
évidemment évidemment
est donc d'abord on est on est on est un
acteur légitime dans cette région on a
des relations
intéressant avec l'inde et l inde était
un pays non alignés qui après fait ses
courses d'armé mots ses marchés
en union soviétique et aujourd'hui ils
achètent beaucoup en france et en israël
et je pense que l'inde
pourrait être ses grandes acteurs avec
lesquels on peut s'arranger ils n'ont
pas exigé un contrat il ya pas longtemps
oui donc c'est toujours vrai c'est
toujours très problématique et disons
qu'on me dire les choses gentiment les
conditions d'attribution des marchés
publics là bas sont courts yeux voilà
donc on dit les choses comme ça c'est
compliqué politiquement autrement mais
c'est un acteur qui pour des raisons
géostratégiques
c'est pas sûr que ils vont s'aligner sur
les états unis comme l'australie par
exemple pour des raisons de civilisation
des géostratégie et c'est donc je pense
que la france a un rôle à jouer il n'y a
pas beaucoup de pays au monde qui
fabrique des plateformes de dire les
avions de chasse comme le rafale il n'y
a pas beaucoup de pays qui fabriquent il
ya trois ou quatre pays comme ça qui
fabrique des avions de ce niveau là et
ce qui se passe maintenant avec cette
cette nouvelle entre guillemets guerre
froide qui monte j'espère qu'on va pas y
arriver là c'est dans longtemps nous
disaient les guerres de 21e siècle c'est
contre contre des talibans pour aller
vite pour qu'on a besoin des avions de
chasse comme comme le rafale est sous
eau des sous marins nucléaires pour des
reer pour courir derrière
des
des gens qui courent dans la montagne
avec deux
de kalachnikov et des rpg7 qui de toute
façon vous battre en plus exactement
et donc si des nouveaux dans notre jeu
des guerres l'adversaire est un
adversaire classique c'est-à-dire un
super puissance a soupé puissance
technologique avec des avions de chasse
avec des sous marins avec des missiles
et cetera et cetera on revient vers la
configuration dans la description des
besoins et dans la réflexion stratégique
de la guerre froide du coup les rafales
c'est génial parce que des avions de
très simple bon marché qui sont faites
pour courir derrière des talibans ça
suffit pas pour répondre aux menaces qui
sont en train de monter sur nos horizons
et donc il faut on a des cartes nos
cartes nous pas aussi bonne que les
cartes américaines c'est sûr mais ça
vaut pas mal et est complet dans les
années 60 70
sans
renier sans prévenir son sur notre
alliance
de fond avec l'occident pour aller vite
on peut jouer un rôle entre autres par
exemple c'est peut-être la vocation de
la france je pense que dans dans cette
guerre froide ni les états unis ni la
chine ne souhaite arriver aux conflits
armés mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas y arriver c'est à dire avec les
japon tout a commencé par le faire de
pétrole
quand les américains on appuyait sur le
nouveau bouton au dernier moment et les
japonais se sentait à couler et les
choses ça y'est yamamoto est partie et
c'est parti et donc je pense que je
pense que la france pourrait être c'est
hier qui va tout faire pour empêcher ça
on va vivre d'un détention d'un des
conflits il faudrait choisir son son
dekel de son camp de temps en temps mais
globalement entre ces deux monstres qui
risque qui risque par erreur mise
calculations politique intérieure et
c'est d'arriver en conflit on pourrait
jouer
cet acteur tiers qui empêche le pire
mais ben ali
oui ce qu'il faut bien voir en fait et
pourquoi il ne faut pas rentrer dans ce
jeu de l'affrontement c'est que au fond
que ce soit la chine et les dirigeants
chinois xi jinping en tête ou que ce
soit les états unis donnent à 30 ans
entend joe biden aujourd'hui
l'affrontement entre ces deux grandes
puissances est véritablement un
fédérateur dans les deux pays en chine
ça permet ainsi j'aime pin de justifier
un durcissement de son régime qu'il
trouvait du fait de l'émergence de la
propagation fait des nouvelles
technologies du fait d'un certain
laisser aller ou depuis une quinzaine
d'années en chine avec finalement
l'impression on n'avait pas gagné en
liberté mais on pouvait vivre on pouvait
se parler on pouvait on pouvait agir de
manière beaucoup plus vivre que ce
n'était le cas par le passé et est
finalement les laines l'émergence de
certaines contestations qui a fait peur
donc il ya une reprise en main qui est
justifiée par cet affrontement par ce
durcissement côté américain et côté
américain la bulle c'est une question la
question chinoise c'est une question qui
est bipartisane pendant rappelez-vous au
début de la campagne présidentielle sur
quoi et haut débit la wii de la campagne
sur quoi donald trump a attaqué joe
biden qu'il appelait sleepy jo c'était
sur son incapacité à être ferme face à
la chine et joe biden a dû donner des
gages à ses électeurs que il était
capable d'être au moins aussi ferme que
d'autres et c'est exactement ça qui se
joue aujourd'hui est en fait si les
australiens en son temps sont venus
chercher les français pour acheter des
sous marins et pour négocier également
un accord de coopération de la même
manière que ça ça a été fait pas par le
japon
à peu près à la même période c'est parce
qu'il ne souhaitait pas rentrer dans ce
jeu d'ego de ces deux grandes puissances
qui manoeuvre et qui s'affrontent pour
satisfaire leurs opinions publiques et
parce qu'elle cherche à acquérir ou à
garder un leadership mondial donc très
clairement la france comme l'europe
comme ces pays que l'on pourrait
qualifier de raisonnable on t'a ont une
carte à jouer et d'autant plus comme
cela a été rappelé parce que la france
est présente de l'océan indien jusqu'à
l'océan pacifique donc elle est présente
à l'inde au pacifique est là elle a été
la première en parmi les pays européens
a rédigé une stratégie indo pacifique
elle a même plutôt pousser ses voisins à
en faire de même en fait donc on sent
bien que la france est peut-être plus
légitime que d'autres mais c'est c'est
quelque part la voie la voie raisonnable
que la voix française que la voie
européenne
c'est cette voix qui s'opposent à une
guerre froid qui de tout n'a rien de bon
temps à porter parce que déjà les
relations économiques entre l'occident
et de l'ensemble de la planète et la
chine sont être extrêmement forte et
extrêmement important les
interdépendances sont importantes et
donc il ya aussi à perdre dans une
opposition dans un affrontement il ya
aussi à perdre de ceux de ce point de
vue là et puis ensuite parce que ça a
été rappelé tout à l'heure parce que les
lélés les crises possible et les risques
finalement que ça y est une escalade et
que y ait à un moment donné à un conflit
petit bug on va récupérer suivi bat
aînés gilbert elle et françois là
puisqu'on parle d'armement et
d'armements américains et de possibles
affrontements
entre les états unis et la chine les
quand même très étonnant de se dire que
l'armement américain celui là même que
les australiens viennent
vient de commander il est truffée
d'électronique chinoise
ce désir bas les américains se
fournissent en semi conducteurs etc etc
en chine j'imagine que dans les
sous-marins américains aujourd'hui il ya
l'électronique chinoises dans les haies
les avions de chasse américains et de
l'autre chimiques chinoises dans les
nôtres aussi et d'électronique chinoise
d'ailleurs mais est ce qu'on n'a pas
peur en cas de conflit qu'une partie du
matériel de l'armement
soit tout à coup tombe en panne donc
d'abord j'espère qu'on a peur parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on cherche qu on
trouve de solution après j'ai pas
d'informations somme pour les états unis
ça m'étonnerait énormément qui a des
composants importants il ya actuellement
je veux qu'à 17 livres la flotte forte
hausse bien sûr non médiatisé le sujet
du livre oui alors il ya peut-être mais
mais je n'ai pas d'information mais j'ai
dit à mon avis les américains pourraient
utiliser davis made in china oui mais
dans guerre les chinois peut pas appuyer
sur un bouton et davies et toutes les
vis made in china je joue à gauche avec
électronique qui est pour elle c'est pas
impossible c'est pas impossible je ne
sais pas mais je pense que les
américains sont au courant de ces décès
de ces risques et qu'ils font quelque
chose pour définir ce qu'on pose qu'on
peut pas et c est d'ailleurs comme on a
appris pendant la crise d'oka vide c'est
pas juste un problème de contrôler les
choses et aussi en cours les y'a bon
approvisionnement en pièces de rechange
etc etc maîtrise des technologies et
cetera dont ça m'étonnerait si de
composants qui sont considérés comme
stratégiques et vitaux
sont achetés toujours un chef d'oeuvre
il ya 15 ans mais j'ai pas
d'informations donc je peux pas aller
plus loin que ça
sylvie bettelli même question c'est le
sujet je le dis c'est de le sujet de ce
roman la flamme fantôme écrite par un un
membre du département d'état américain
et comme quoi effectivement c'est à peu
près la date que vous citez kazan où
tout ce qui a été tué tout ce qui a été
ht avec duo fabriqués avec des
composants chinois seraient voués à ne
pas être utilisé en cas de conflit parce
que je n'aurai plus la maîtrise alors ça
m'étonnerait je rejoins je rejoins ce
qui vient d'être dit ça m'étonnerait que
les américains se soient amusés à
introduire des composants chinois dans
leur armement je pense qu'ils ont s'il
l'avait fait il aurait fait pour des
raisons de coût mais il aurait forcément
double source et en américain pour être
prêt le moment venu à utiliser du
matériel américain très clairement je ne
crois pas par contre c'est une vraie
question c'est une vraie question pour
les armements européens et en
particulier français avec un certain
nombre de composants américains qui sont
sur nos sûrement sur nos armements sur
nos systèmes sur le système d'armes et
qui nous pénalise très souvent si le si
certains armements le rafale ou autres
n'ont pas été exportées pendant des
années c'est qu'il était sous le coup de
la réglementation de contrôle des
exportations américaines la
réglementation qui s'appelle guitare et
qui oblige les français lors ce qu'ils
exportent des composants américains mis
sous des systèmes ou des sous systèmes
d'armement français a demandé
l'autorisation aux états unis qui bien
évidemment quand ils ne souhaitaient pas
que nous accédions à ce marché nous
refuser cette autorisation
donc ça c'est le cas mais pas pour les
etats-unis c'est le cas pour les
européens et pour certains des
équipements de français alors il y
aurait stimulé d'ouvrir des maîtres
système comme les gps
qui pop ça pourrait poser quand même un
problème parce que il faut même même le
système galileo en cas de guerre
peut-être il faudrait qu'on se rabat
sont l'autre système donc il ya des
choses il ya forcément de dépendance où
on peut pas avoir de raison dans ce
partout sont tous il nous reste huit
minutes
c'est quoi le l'autre étage de la fusée
pour vous guide me rallie à toute cette
affaire grave à explorer un certain
nombre de conséquences mais on peut
aller encore un peu plus loin alors
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure il ya la
question
je crois pas la défense européenne
dans les sens où on ne rend pas une idée
l'europe avec un pentagone
européenne qui sera une semaine à dresde
est une semaine à une semaine à orléans
je crois pas du tout en revanche je
crois à des systèmes airbus c'est à dire
j'aimerais bien que les allemands avec
nous on va 1 semble construire
développer et construire en europe un
avion des chats sont en plateforme
aérienne sixième génération et d'autre
systèmes d'autres plateformes important
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire dans le
domaine des drones et dans d'autres
domaines
encore et et d'avoir une des grès
d'autonomie on sera jamais indépendant
vis-à-vis des etats-unis c'est pas
possible mais il faut il faut des dégrés
d'autonomie qui permet aussi de marge de
manoeuvre et il faut aussi avoir
toujours face aux américains d'avoir
quelque chose dont ils ont besoin pour
négocier
parce qu'elle est depuis ce que ce soit
la première guerre mondiale deuxième
guerre mondiale
c'étaient deux des guerres des grands
coalition et les patrons de ces skis
soit pershing oc soir einsenhower et au
marshall
c'était des diplomates qui négociaient
tout le temps et chacun tirait dans son
côté ils sont ils ont fait un consensus
et est par exemple la deuxième guerre
mondiale le la carte de la france
étaient des territoires outre mer
c'était l'afrique si on n'a pas ignoré
complètement des gaules
côté allemand aussi s'il y avait une
valeur pour vichy d'un côté pour des
gaules de l'autre c'est parce qu'ils
avaient l'afrique et parce qu'il y avait
d'autres choses sinon on serait
n'existerait plus donc il faut voir
quels sont notre carte on a des cartes
important il faut réaliser que ne sont
pas un super puissance
et que j'avais
jamais les îles marshall et chaque fois
mais chaque fois chaque fois j'ai
l'impression qu'on découvre des nouveaux
qu'on n'est pas au niveau des états unis
et donc il faut jouer à notre niveau il
faut boxer pas 120 kilos mais à 60 kg et
il faut avoir une médaille d'or dans ce
sens qu'ils ont
sévi la tv alors l'étape suivante pour
moi ce sont les américains qui vont
essayer de rallier à leur cause autant
de pays que possible ils vont commencer
bien évidemment en asie pacifique et
avec les japonais et pro peut-être
tenter les indiens puis ils vont tenter
de convaincre les européens et il ya
trois-quatre jours de ça je vous aurais
dit ouh là je suis inquiète parce que vu
le manque de réaction des européens pas
sûr qu'il soit prêt je pense qu'ils ont
été choqués
a étonné voire choqué par ce qui s'est
passé mais il ne la supprimerons pas ils
n'oseront pas s'opposer à ce satané
américain or ce qui est en train de se
passer à bruxelles dans les capitales
européennes est assez intéressante cet
après-midi oui peut-être hier le temps
passe trop vite une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères qui a
barré de l'agenda la préparation d'une
réunion qui devait s'organiser avec les
états unis pour discuter des
technologies militaires donc voyez on a
quand même on a quand même des
frémissements de réaction qui ça
pourrait être assez ferme de la part des
européens avec cette idée européen que
les américaines ne peuvent pas faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent et peut-être
qu'on se laissera pas forcément
convaincre on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'europe de la défense et et du fait que
quand on est en afrique ce sont d'abord
les français qui sont présents c'est
vrai c'est une réalité ça nous coûte
d'ailleurs très très cher mais il il ya
un petit signal qui est assez
intéressant même si les choses vont trop
lentement mais il ya aussi des estoniens
aujourd'hui en afrique est ce que vous
auriez imaginé il ya dix ans que les
estoniens déploierait des troupes en
afrique moi je peux vous dire que je
vous aurais pris pour pour un doux
rêveur si vous m'aviez parlé il ya une
dizaine d'années donc effectivement
l'étape suivante ça va être les
américains qui vont essayer de d'imposer
dans le concept le nouveau concept
stratégique de l'otan cet affrontement à
la chine espérons qu'on va tenir bon et
qu'on va s'y oppose et je crois qu'on a
des intérêts nationaux divers et variés
en europe c'est certain mais malgré tout
des liens économiques une dépendance
économique une interdépendance
économique qui vont nous pousser à être
beaucoup plus modérée dans notre
approche donc ça ce sera l'étape
suivante et puis et puis après on essaie
un petit peu loin pour faire la
prospective et six jeunes et aux et je
me tromperais très certainement et est
alors dernier point les chinois et puis
les russes aussi qu'ils regardent cette
affaire et qui dans n'importe quoi à
votre avis ah bon jeu d'abord je pense
que les chinois étaient surpris
et qu'il 132 calculé lors
l'eau réaction
les chinois en grand problème parce que
la stratégie chinoise dépit depuis 2010
11 12 coûte très cher et les dividendes
sont
pour le moment pas au rendez vous par
exemple la route de la soie ils
dépensent décembre inimaginable
on voit pas encore
le rêve de tish un ping qui a train
d'être réalisé on voit en revanche que
le lot réserve comment ça commence à
fondre il ya aussi quelques crises
économiques qui sont à l'horizon en
chine parce que on peut pas jouer les
jeux capitaliste sein
les montagnes russes qui vont avec
et est donc c'est il faut pas tomber
dans le piège de la guerre froide où on
pensait tout le temps à quel point nous
sommes nuls et les russes sont
imbattables géniaux que les mig milk 21
on n'a pas de réponse les vignes 25
c'est la fin du monde c'est c est
finalement ça s'est écroulé comme si
c'était un décor d'hollywood donc je dis
pas que c'est ça le site change in mais
les chinois sont aussi en difficulté
ils ont pas mal de défis tout ne marche
pas comme il le souhaite et et c'est à
dire que c'est d'autant plus une chance
pour la france d'avoir ce genre de
chambre de champ de manoeuvre cette
stratégie de la raison des passionnés et
là je pense qu'on a un boulevard devant
lui matelly même question la chine la
russie dans cette affaire alors la chine
et la russie ont tout à gagner en fait
atteint d'une division
entre européens d'abord et puis entre
entre donner une loi ne ment ou d'un
antiaméricanisme croissant en europe ça
c'est ça c'est certain
nous ne verrons pas d'un bon oeil
l'alignement des européens sur d'autres
d'autres pays d'autres démocraties en
asie et dans le pacifique ça c'est
certain égal la chine aujourd'hui sa
plus grande difficulté c'est qu'elle
n'arrive pas à stimuler sa consommation
intérieure et donc elle est encore
énormément captivé dépendante de ses
exportations et on voit que après la
crise du coc vide ya quand même toute
une discussion qui est un débat qui
s'est ouvert en europe mais aussi aux
états unis pour relocaliser une partie
de notre industrie pour réduire nos
dépendance vis-à-vis de la chine et ça
c'est un vrai défi pour les chinois et
ce qui est incompréhensible c'est que si
j'aime pin profite de ce moment là pour
durcir le ton alors même qu'il devrait
aller se chercher des alliés et qu'il
aurait toutes les raisons d'aller les
chercher que ce soit en asie pacifique
où que ce soit en europe or bas ils
jouent ils jouent un jeu qui pourrait le
desservir à moyen terme alors les les
déterminants de ça c'est pas très
objectif c'est que lui joue le jeu de sa
position au sein du parti communiste
chinois et donc ils essayent de se
renforcer il essaye d'assurer sa survie
d'assurer son avenir politique et
d'assurer son avenir politique dans la
durée ça n'est probablement pas
l'intérêt de la chine et les
conséquences politiques sociales
économiques de ce durcissement donc très
certainement pesé dans les années qui
viennent rappelons que la chine est
aussi l'un des pays au monde qui vit le
plus vite avec une population qui va
diminuer dans les années qui viennent et
je vous arrête là merci je suis matelly
l'édile me rallie le temps qui nous
était imparti est écoulé merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]